North Korea will be at the top of the
agenda next week when President Trump
welcomed South Korea's new president for
a White House summit this morning our
Norah O'Donnell has the first one-on-one
interview with moon jae-in since he was
elected he spoke about his approach to
solving the crisis with North Korea
Norah Jones us again from Seoul where
the changing dynamics with the changing
dynamics in the region Norah good
morning hey good morning Charlie it has
been fascinating to be here on the
ground and do some reporting about what
is going to be this fundamental shift in
policy in dealing with the North Koreans
president moon told us that he believes
the Obama administration's policy of
strategic patience was a failure in his
words so he wants to restart dialogue
with the North Koreans the question is
how is that going to happen when Kim
jong-un has promised to make this
country South Korea in his words a sea
of fire President Trump has called Kim
Jong on a madman with nuclear weapons do
you believe that he is a madman and why
do you want to talk to a madman
Kim do Mooney Kim jong-un is not a
rational person but I would like to also
note that President Trump once even
mentioned he is willing to talk with Kim
jong-un over a burger and that he has
another point he mentioned that it would
be an honor to be able to meet kim
jung-han so I believe president Trump
went much further than I did do you
believe that Kim jong-un likes burgers
mm-hmm a model man most likely maybe
most likely ginger murupara younger son
so I believe what Kim jong-un would want
the most is to have a security guarantee
for his regime so there is a possibility
that Kim jong-un continues to make the
bluff with his nuclear weapons programs
he went deep inside he is actually
yearning or wanting dialogue there in
the end the only way to find out is to
have a dialogue with North Korea
let me ask you it is the view of US
intelligence that North Korea will
likely test an ICBM this year would you
oppose a preemptive strike by the United
States
to take that out before the test
O'Connor I believe when it comes to
North Korea's nuclear missile threats
it is the Republic of Korea that is more
dire for the United States the North
Korean threat is a future threat on the
horizon for us this is a matter of life
and death when it comes to preemptive
strike that you mentioned I believe that
this is something we may we can discuss
at a later stage when the threat has
become even more urgent so is that your
message for President Trump when you
meet with him at the White House turn on
so I believe that we will probably have
such discussions the two of us will both
be in office and working together for
the next five years and the two of us
also share the common goals of resolving
the North Korean nuclear issue
establishing a peace regime on the
Korean Peninsula and building peace and
security in Northeast Asia so if the two
of us could pull together and accomplish
these common goals then I believe that
this will be the most fruitful
achievements that we can achieve during
our terms in office and I also believe
that this will be the greatest
diplomatic achievement for president
Trump as well you believe that his
greatest diplomatic achievement will be
what happens here on the Korean
Peninsula Chris interpreter to me yes
that is because President Trump has
mentioned that North Korea was on the
top of his priority list
and also because this is something that
all the former u.s. administration's I
could not achieve certain parameters and
so I highly commend president Trump's
placing such great importance on the
North Korean nuclear issue and I also
believe that thanks to president Trump's
approach and attitude there is a
possibility of resolving this issue you
have promised to sit me to me
head-to-head with the North Korean
dictator can you go to Pyongyang this
year
can you meet with him this year Oh turn
on I certainly hope that the conditions
could become right for such dialogue
before the end of the year and just
because we believe the dialogue is
necessary does not mean that we have to
be impatient for dialogue and so what I
hope to achieve by the end of this year
is to draw North Korea out to the table
for negotiation through the
imitation from various and strong
sanctions and pressure you have laid out
very ambitious goals how can you achieve
what others have been unable to achieve
we got Kumamoto yeah there was a time
when we got very close to achieving that
goal
this is not my unilateral initiative
this is also an initiative that had been
pursued by the United States in the past
and you will ask President Trump to
renew that if I have the opportunity yes
Thank You mr. president
thank you
so so as you just heard there's been a
lot of news made out of this interview
there has also already been a diplomatic
kerfuffle if you will ahead of President
moons visit to meet with Trump one of
his advisers informal advisors is
actually in Washington this week and
suggested that South Korea would be
willing to scale back military exercises
with the u.s. so we asked president moon
to clarify that is that on the table is
that concession on the table and he said
it is not there's certainly a lot to
discuss there Nora here's a question for
you how likely do you think it is that
the two leaders will meet North Korea
and South Korea mr. moon and kim
jeong-hoon face to face you aware this
year is over yeah I mean that that's the
question I said can you get it done this
year and he said he hoped he's hopeful
that the conditions would be set for
such a meeting so they're working
towards that he wasn't you know willing
to say that he hopes it happens this
year but that is certainly a goal to set
the conditions for that and he's the one
who brought up that president Trump in
the past has said that he'd be willing
to share a burger with Kim jong-un so
the possibility imagine of even
President Trump having a face-to-face
meeting with Kim jong-un those are I
think are are in the in the distance not
likely to happen anytime soon if at all
but the fact that that's being raised is
an interesting diplomatic tool that's
being used at this time does moon jaein
want to see North Korea and South Korea
United something that the Chinese are
very opposed to yeah I mean that's a
great question charlie because not only
is he promising a freeze in nuclear
weapons in an ultimate denuclearization
he is also talking about a peace
agreement
uniting North in South
and as you know that's been an elusive
goal since the end of the Korean War
sixty-four years ago so that comes with
its own set of complications and there's
a lot of concern to about talking about
unification and those sorts of things
before you before you you deal with the
issue of nuclear weapons that that has
to be dealt with before anything else
nor thank you very much
good job we'll have more doors interview
software is president on our streaming
network cbsn you can watch on the CBS
News app or at CBS news.com